la folie pokémon fait fureur chez nos
bambins après les jeux vidéos les cartes
à jouer sortie aujourd'hui du dessin
animé pokémon avec ces étranges
personnages imaginaires venus du japon
mais plus que ce film a bien ce sont
surtout les produits dérivés qui font
recette dans les cours de récréation
un phénomène de mode qui coûte aussi
très cher aux parents stéphane dupas si
vous avez des enfants vous savez
forcément de quoi on parle
pikachu c'est le petit lapin qui envoie
des décharges électriques
lui et ses 150 copains pokémon occupe
100 % du temps de vos enfants
beaucoup possèdent ce que laissait le
jeu pokémon cdm boys puis quelques cas
au début c'était donc un jeu vidéo
numéro un des ventes au japon aux états
unis et en france maintenant on classe
on collectionne des cartes l'avenir par
et il appartient aux pokémon l'année
2010 et l'année 2011 sera pokémon tout
simplement parce que ben au japon nous
avons vu fleurir de nouveaux jeux
pokémon gold et pokémon silver
donc il est très clair que
on a pas fini avec ses bêtes qu'il
s'agit de faire évoluer grâce au combat
gagné contre d'autres pokémon
le but c'est de devenir grand maître en
capturant le maximum de monstres un
monde virtuel voire violent mais qui
permettrait à l'enfant de s'affirmer
la dimension excitante de ces règles
c'est qu'elle lui donne vraiment le
sentiment de se rapprocher de cette
inaccessibilité donc un sentiment de
puissance de pouvoir le film déjà sorti
aux états unis a rapporté 600 millions
de francs
rassurez vous la suite est prévue pour
la fin de l'année de quoi occuper vos
enfants pendant un moment
sauf si d'ici là une nouvelle nouveauté
éclipsé pokémon alors un petit coup